l'habitante peut survenir ralentir le
rythme calme et le corps et l'esprit
c'est le gros défi dans les écoles en
on remarque la des crises de panique qui
sont plus nombreuses parfois dans les
classes des élèves qui ont de la
difficulté à rester concentré des élèves
qui ont la difficulté à faire en cour au
complet le fait qu' on se fait comparer
quand on est jeune tous les jours à tous
les moments de la journée avec les
médias sociaux la performance scolaire
les parents sont très exigeants les
collèges privés etc
donc il ya beaucoup d'anxiété chez nos
jeunes 17 à 20% des élèves du secondaire
ont reçu un diagnostic pour une forme ou
une autre d'anxiété pour combattre le
problème québec veut étendre le
programme baptisé hors piste sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais jean les abonnés
j'ai depuis l'automne dernier comme on
le voit dans ce documentaire une
vingtaine d'écoles ont d'abord présenté
cinq ateliers sur l'anxiété à des
classes complètes et depuis janvier on a
formé des groupes plus restreints comme
ici à l'école saint-jean-baptiste ou six
élèves sont inscrits
chaque rencontre débute avec une
méditation et tremblements la cara qui
boit plus vite figées où ça c'est une
des sensations physiques qui viennent
avec les stress l'objectif est
d'apprendre aux jeunes à identifier et à
gérer le stress
on parle de s'exposer on parle de
comment règne au conflit comme aux
familles aux rythmes questions
personnelles comment s'expose aux
réseaux sociaux donc c'est vraiment des
aptitudes qu'on leur ment cinq ateliers
de 90 minutes pour comprendre comment
composer avec le stress et faire face à
l'anxiété plutôt qu'essayer de l'éviter
défi qui commence hors piste et ça m'a
beaucoup aidé parce que j'ai prêché à
trouver beaucoup de stratégies épi
cherche à accomplir des vitres et qui
m'as tu me mettre hors de ma zone de
confort
on aborde aussi la gestion des émotions
et l'affirmation de soi
finalement on se penche sur la
comparaison sociale plus forte que
jamais à l'ère des médias sociaux des
outils qui ont réduit le stress de
samuel j'aurais jeu manquait presque
tout le temps et que ce sas avant je
trouve vraiment que ça a eu un gros
progrès dans ce sens qui pensent ça doit
faire quand même assez longtemps que
j'ai pas eu mal au ventre
il développe sa résilience ce qui est
l'objectif principal du programme un
attitude de personnes combattante qui
affronte qui est tout en sachant ce que
ça peut lui faire c'est du courage dans
le temps
on essaie de leur donner un des problème
qu'on a c'est l'augmentation de
prescription de médicaments pour nous
pour nos jeunes l'antidépresseur et ça
c'est si on trouve des termes thérapies
alternatives
ça va ça va nous aider beaucoup à
diminuer le nombre de prescriptions
en septembre le nombre d'écoles qui
bénéficient de ce programme va doubler
québec promet plus de professionnels
pour y arriver ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada montréal